the Joe Rogan experience so then there
was the whole section that you probably
remember about chicken and fish causing
cancer dairy products causing cancer
they started to just it really kind of
went from just like you can do well on a
plant-based diet as an athlete to like
animal products are horrible and I'm
gonna kill you
which was a you know a big leap so they
had one study James Wilks says you know
research funded by the National Cancer
Institute found that vegetarians who had
one or more servings per week of white
meat like chicken and fish more than
tripled their risk of colon cancer well
that's scary you know I don't want to
triple my risk of colon cancer but again
if you look at the totality of the
research slide 42 Jamie 2017 a
meta-analysis of 16 prospective studies
with with almost two and a half million
participants found no increase in cancer
risk from consuming fish or poultry and
then you have a statement from the
American Cancer Institute itself saying
as for other animal products
organizations that do comprehensive
evidence reviews to make dietary
recommendations currently do not
recommend against poultry like chicken
turkey ground or fresh fish or dairy so
where's that coming from then one study
that looked at seventh-day Adventists
who added some of those foods back into
their diet this is a perfect example of
healthy user bias because seventh-day
Adventists are not supposed to eat meat
so if you have a seventh-day adventists
who's bucking the trend and eating meat
then what else are they doing that is
also not healthy and not following the
dictates of that healthy lifestyle mmm
that was like that into consideration
they didn't asked him whether their
drinking I was a six-year study in the
seventh-day adventists cohort from 1976
to 1982 and it was what I call them SDA
rebels you know the they're supposed to
eat vegetarian but they on meat so what
else are they doing that's kind of
conducting and the reason why this is
relevant is this is the only study that
we know of that does show a correlation
between there might be other
individual studies that do but this is
why we have these large reviews they
look at you know this one looked at
sixteen studies with two and a half
million participants and found no
association and then that's why you have
groups like the American Cancer
Institute who say you know this
recommend well I mean people are up in
arms at the most recent recommendation
that can't that we people have been told
to avoid red meat oh yeah and then they
said well actually there's no risk at
all eating red meat we're taking that
off of the list of foods to avoid and
everybody went hey [ __ ] they just went
apeshit let's talk about the lack of a
better term yeah they did they freaked
out yes conflicts with the dogma
absolutely and this was this was a five
paper review so it wasn't just one paper
was five papers all in one review it was
millions of participants you know they
reviewed all of the available literature
on red meat you know and in its
relationship with any disease heart
disease cancer type two diabetes
it was dozens of studies following
people for up to thirty five years and
millions again millions of participants
they looked at randomized controlled
trials they looked at observational
cohort studies they looked at all kinds
of outcomes on the total mortality
cardiovascular cancer etc and they found
quote only low or very low certainty
evidence that red meat causes any kind
of disease and in in the editorial in
the annals which is what it was
published annals of internal medicine
the journal was published and they said
quote this is slide nineteen Jamie over
and over again they the authors stressed
that even if the results were
statistically significant their
certainty was low and the absolute
difference is seen were small and
potentially confounded meaning could
have been that they were smoking more
drinking more or right you know not
exercises or whatever the editorial also
said this is sure to be controversial
but it's based on the most comprehensive
review of the evidence to date because
that review is inclusive those who seek
to dispute it will be hard-pressed to
find appropriate evidence
with which to build an argument unless
you have a nice documentary yeah you
just put in whatever [ __ ] yeah yeah
the really frustrating thing for people
is also recommend process its
unprocessed and processed so the the dog
men always been well to stay away from
processed meat and you universe some
studies showed no difference with fresh
but some difference with the process
read me you know I think you could make
a stronger argument that process too
much processed meat might be harmful
because of things like in nitroso
compounds that are formed etc but even
then you have to consider context most
people are eating hot dogs with buns and
french fries and big gulps well right it
might it's probably a different effect
than having bacon a couple times a week
with your whole foods diet or having
some salami and nuts you know not the
same as eating you know fake processed
meat all the time and one of the things
that's weird about this whole
conversation is it's it's there's a
battleground so like a volley gets
thrown out there like this like boom
it's okay to eat red meat and you see
the other side scrambling to refute the
evidence and and then fire back with all
these epidemiology studies that show
that red meat can kill you and red meats
causing an age quicker red meat kills
your boners and red meat does this and
does that and it's like it's it's with
there's a religious war going on it's
the same weird thing we were talking
about earlier now when you have some
kind of political event or some event
that happens it gets spun you know if
you go watch CNN it's going to get spun
one way if you go watch Fox it's going
to get spun the other way it's the same
event but you have these totally
different interpretations yeah
[Applause]